could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
i think society goes success is get this
job get married get a house what does
that do to you it just really makes your
life feel small the founder of kloss
boss monthly fitness program a billion
dollar founder wild scanacchio when i
would watch my parents not really fit in
it sort of made me realize maybe i don't
fit in and then be told i smelled or i
didn't belong somewhere everyone wanted
to box me into something and i just
refused to be boxed we spent half a
million dollars building a product that
didn't work was i exhausted yes was i
lonely yeah i missed family things i
missed weddings i i was just not around
i have learned at this point like time
means more to me than money i want to
make sure my priorities are more
reflective of the human i want to be in
my life
if you go towards purpose i guarantee
your life will be more fulfilling do you
believe that everybody has a purpose
beyond the nine to five i do how do you
find it so
first of all
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
when i read someone's story one of the
first questions i try and answer when
i'm reading through that especially the
early years is i'm trying to identify
what it is that made them
either an anomaly or
hungry i have a kind of a thesis that
much of people's drive and their
ambition especially the people that i
sit here with comes from kind of some
kind of pain or trauma or early
experience that molded them so my
question to you
is what made you hungry
you know when i was younger i got to
taste something that was so magical
which was
dance and
it was this place in my life that it
wasn't about the physicality of actually
dancing it was
the ability to make other people feel
through something that i did and to be
able to realize that as a human
being you can have
that type of influence power connection
to other people and to feel that
when you are
four or five years old
was just this magical experience for me
that honestly nothing else in my life
could compare to it and once i uncovered
that i always wanted to feel that
in anything i did and i strived in all
the work i did and all
of you know the different careers i've
had in my life and the different you
know art i've done
i've strived always to go back to that
intention of how
do i give to others and make them feel
something in their life and that's
really been this anchor for me and its
purpose at the end of the day
and that started at five years old yeah
when i was really young with a don't set
a wedding yeah it was just a random
dance performance that
for some reason i started dancing and
everyone started watching me and i it
wasn't anything that was a
structured performance by any means it
was very much just this organic thing
that came out of me
and
i really just loved it and i realized
actually in a deeper way that the other
part of the hunger came from
when i danced and felt that feeling i
felt like the most authentic version of
me
and i realized that i was in so many
settings where i didn't always feel like
i could be me
whether that was you know being an
indian girl in the middle of a town
where no one looked like me or sometimes
being with my indian community but being
in a town that where i was a cheerleader
and i didn't fit in there i realized
that so many parts of me never felt
whole and i was always showing up with
one little strand of me one little
strand of me there here
and i felt when i performed and danced
especially indian dance i felt like the
most
whole version of who i was
the resistance you felt and the struggle
you felt of bit trying to
i guess conform to two different
communities at the same time so tell me
about trying to be an
american in in a town where there's
you know 300 people at your school and
you're the only
people of indian heritage how is that i
think one of the most interesting parts
of it is so much of this comes from the
parents not really from the kids
and when i would watch my parents not
really fit in it sort of made me realize
maybe i don't fit in it was sort of this
interesting way
to look at my parents and know that they
felt uncomfortable and then look at
myself and be in different settings and
realize wait i don't look like everyone
else and then be told i smelled or my
food smelled or i didn't belong
somewhere because
my hair color was different
was just a very interesting
place to be kids said that she yeah i
remember like i mean i talk about it in
my book but there were some some really
harsh moments you know and when you're
young you're you're impressionable right
things can scar you for a very long time
and i think for me the the goodness was
that i did have this place of dance that
made me feel
grounded and made me feel whole because
if i didn't have that i think the trauma
that i was probably going through by not
fitting in would have just burned a hole
so deep in me that i'm not sure how i
would have been able to recover but i
had this light right
and i think that's you know going back
to what you were asking
it was the light
that i saw that there is something
beautiful out there for me to go and do
for the world if i can just hang on to
it and fight for it and it was a fight
for me to even hang on to whatever my
identity was right when we talk about
our identities and in all these labels
which i really don't love like whether
it's indian american ceo whatever all
these labels are it was really just i
think my whole journey in my life
was a fight to be myself in any setting
and not have people tell me what to do
right i think we all struggle with that
in our whole lives and probably why i
had to be a ceo because i don't like
anyone telling me what to do but it
really stemmed because i think
throughout my life everyone wanted to
box me into something
and i just refused to be boxed did your
parents want to box you into something
of course i mean my parents you know
they sacrificed everything to come to
america they obviously wanted my sister
and i
to have successful careers which you
know amounted to a few different
industries like be a doctor a lawyer
engineer or you know and then the other
part of it was get married you know
obviously at like a normal age where you
could
cook for your family and be a good wife
right these were sort of the
these were the expectations that were
set in my life and i think that's really
the hardest part is when you are
constantly
brought in your life in saying that you
need to
live by the expectations of others you
end up either rebelling or you conform
and
i always wanted to make my parents proud
so
i knew i did what i felt was at the core
part of the value so for example if it
was getting education i thought that was
important too i wasn't going to sit
there and rebel from getting education
but there came a point in my career
trajectory where i had to say okay like
i have checked every box in this now i
have to do it my way with the way i
really want to feel and not conform and
rebel and i think that's really the
whole formula of people knowing when to
rebel and when to conform
you referenced that um you were looking
for a different feeling
after checking those boxes what was the
feeling you had when you were doing that
job
i had trained myself my entire life to
do well when people told me to
hit this mark in my life right and
that's like in a way that's like how i
developed the skills in my life to to
always propel myself and execute and
make sure that um i was able to you know
be responsible and move forward in
everything i did
but
i felt no deep
fire or passion or love towards it right
i wasn't jumping out of my bed
to go to my office to go and work for my
clients right i was doing what i had to
because you know i knew it was
once again expected of me when you you
must have friends that are living a life
that is
expected of them
and you can start to see as the the
years go on the consequence of living a
life that is expected of you
absolutely what would you say to those
people
and what lessons have you learned about
living a life expected of you i mean
that's not the way to have a fulfilled
life you can have a life and you can
probably
check all the boxes and make your people
proud in your life but you're going to
be on the other side of it and feel
empty
and that feeling of emptiness is the
worst feeling anyone can ever have and i
think people come to it at different
points in their life they either come to
it when they're 20 or they come to it
when they're 50.
and
that's because they haven't done the
work to actually ask themselves
what are the expectations you want for
your own life and that's the problem i
think we're never taught that right no
one's ever
asked
us what we want for our own lives and i
think society goes and tells us okay
success is get this job successes get
married get a house have kids you know
and especially for women it's even i
think even a bit more of a closed road
and that what does that do to you it
just really
it makes your life feel small right
because it makes you feel like you can't
get past it to go and live for your
dreams and ultimately you know i've been
there in my life where i have felt like
the road has closed in
and it's left me feeling hopeless
and that's the worst place in the world
to be is feeling hopeless the best thing
you could do is feel like you can go and
do anything change the world and i think
the more you taste it the more you want
more of it in your life
at that phase in your life were you
battling somewhat with your
north star that light you referenced
earlier which was dancing
but also you're i guess you're nine to
five yeah and what tell me about that
battle in how
dance ultimately ended up winning i
remember always having this bounce in my
step like i would walk to work in the
middle of new york city choreographing
in my head listening to
the song i was performing like i in a
weird way was like embodying this life
that of what i wanted to be
and then i would get to the office and i
would do my work and you know once again
like i i love the steve martin quote be
so good they can't ignore you like
whatever work i do in my life i will do
150 if i say yes but
i knew that something was wrong i never
i didn't want to live like that i didn't
want to feel like i was hiding so much
of who i was and as my 95 which by the
way in consulting isn't a nine to five
you work like 80 hours a week i mean
that was my life and i as i realized
that if i wanted to commit to that
career path that that 80 was probably
going to go to 90 it was going to go to
100 was going to be traveling and i was
going to have to say
no more and more to the thing i loved i
just realized i wasn't willing to make
that trade-off and i think that's
sometimes the hardest thing people have
to think about is what are you
sacrificing what's the trade-off in your
life that you're making
and i just wasn't willing to make it at
that point and i i had
done so much in my life at that point
where um i felt like i had achieved
according to everyone else enough to
start taking
a little bit of a path to being
rebellious right and i think that's
really when
i started to do a lot of work to say
what can i do to bring all parts of me
to the table
when you make that decision to leave
bain and company yeah the managing
management consultant firm in new york
was there like a series of catalystic
sort of moments or pivotal moments near
the end of your time there that made you
think i [ __ ] this
you know like i i read about a meeting
you had yeah
yeah so it's literally the opening um of
my book but
you know a few a few things happen i
would say so
first of all most people stay in
consulting like at this this job for
about three years then you go off to
business school it's sort of the usual
route people take so i was in my third
year there and a few people can kind of
stay on and just continue there i really
wasn't interested in going to business
school at the time
i wanted to live i wanted to like be in
new york city and feel the energy of it
and so my third in my third year i had a
performance at um in the middle of times
square for the for this big uh
unveiling of ushuayarai's madame
tussauds statue which was an important
thing and australia rai is one of my
icons especially as a dancer she's a
huge bollywood actress
and the week before a client meeting
gets scheduled at the same time as my
performance
and i'm you know my clients are big
clients these aren't these are fortune
500 companies these aren't small clients
by any means and and we're meeting like
the ceos you know
cfos of the company and um i remember
talking to my boss saying hey you know
what i really want to go to the
performance i'm not like a big part of
this meeting is it okay if i miss it and
we talked about it really briefly it
wasn't a big deal i didn't feel bad
about it i went to the performance
it went well a few months later we're
sitting down talking about you know
review and she's like giving me feedback
and she says this thing to me which just
triggered me and it was
is this the job you really want like i
don't think that you want to be a
consultant and i took that in my heart
as
oh my gosh she doesn't think i'm good
enough right and i just kind of went
through how throughout my life
i've been taught to be type a everyone
tell me i've done a good job
and so my initial reaction to her saying
that to me was i'm going to prove to you
how good i am right that's like the
natural type a reaction is to say no
what do you mean like i love this job i
really want to be here
and
the more i started thinking about that
the more i realized she was right i
didn't want to be there it was not the
life i wanted it was not the career i
wanted and that's when i decided to
start looking at other jobs that
would give me a bit more of the
flexibility i wanted in my day to day
but still pay the bills and that's when
you move over to mtv i went to warner
music right now we warner right okay and
there's this really interesting balance
that i see in you like which clearly
shifts in your life where you you feel
like you're a um and correct me where
i'm wrong here but you're quite a good
like conformist in terms of expectation
and then slowly rebellion starts to
creep in and it was just just had me
thinking about like the probably if
there is a right balance of conformity
and rebellion in our life because
conformity makes sense
you know
in some regards you can't just be a
total robot right we'd all be living out
in the desert or something right but
just the interesting balance i see in
people like you that i meet of
i mean a lot of them start as kind of
conformist or a little bit more
people-pleasing especially
first-generation immigrant families
right and then that fails them
yeah
in terms of fulfillment happiness mental
health
and then that's where the rebellion
starts to
i think that's the key it's it's
rebelling for the right reason if that
makes sense i always believe
that i was rebelling for purpose
right right and if you're rebelling for
purpose
i think it's exactly yeah it's
justifiable right dance wasn't
something that was just okay pile go and
do this because it's a hobby like it it
was this place for me to bring together
so much of my trauma actually from when
i was younger it was this place for me
and and you know my dance company was
this indian american dance experience
and
it was about me bringing together the
pile who got made fun of with the pile
who danced at her indian festivals and
bringing all of me together to say
when the world doesn't want to accept
the different parts of who i am i'm
going to show you what it can look like
right like that's really a big part of
what i've realized in my journey is when
people have told me parts don't fit
together i find a way to put them
together and show you even a more
beautiful experience right and i i
believe even class pass was really the
epitome of that too in my life is
bringing parts of me together that
i would never have been able to bring
together in any other way
and you know i think so much of when
we're rebelling it's about fighting for
something i wasn't i wasn't trying to
rebel i was fighting
for my passion i was fighting for my
purpose and
i mean isn't that what life should be
about is fighting for something like
that amen
when you leave bain and company though
is there a part of you because that
expectation is it's
never really yeah they really fully
shake it right is there a part of you
that whispers in your ear and goes you
failed
oh
i mean what was hard was all my
colleagues right that at that point who
had gone to harvard gone to stanford you
know
i was
comparing myself to them and i felt
like i was taking a step back compared
to what they were doing but one of the
other important things i learned during
this time and i think this is an
important part and for all of us at any
phase especially when we're going
through these transitional times
is i also embraced a new community right
so i obviously didn't just define myself
by my bain and mit friends i had this
huge artistic dance community that was
sort of like growing this indian
american community that was sort of
coming around me
and that made me feel whole in a
different way so instead of constantly
being around people i felt
less than i went and found a community i
belonged in even though it wasn't the
one that i would have you know naturally
feel felt inclined to go to and i think
that's another important thing
especially when we're exploring these
decisions and identities it's you know
back to the light thing it's sometimes
it's not the people we think are going
to give us the light who give us the
light so find that new community that
makes you shine it's such an appreciated
point of resistance for people that are
trying to make an adjustment in their
life i hear it so much people say i want
to levex situation but i'm scared of
losing the community that comes with
that situation that could be a city it
could be a job it could be a partner
sometimes your lives become so
intertwined that you think well if i
lose this partner if i lose this job or
whatever then i'm going to lose all of
these people
and that really keeps people trapped i
agree with that that's right that's a
really good point yeah i mean
and you can find new communities you
know and i think you have to remember
that the people you surround yourself
with are your choice yeah right and i've
had different communities show up for me
at different times in my life right for
me
it was the different communities that
made me the entrepreneur i was it was my
business community that helped me build
class bus but it was also this girl who
was going to ballet classes every single
day with my with my dancer friends who
also was thinking about
the classes that they people need to
take in their life and it was that
unique combination of my traits combined
with the different experiences i was
having that enabled me to build what i
did ultimately you talk about so you
managed to get a now a job you consider
to be more of a nine to five where
you've got time in the evenings to dance
and you end up setting up your own sort
of dance company um how did you get to
from there
to that pivotal trip to san francisco
that introduced you to the world of tech
yeah so in those two years when i was at
warner music group
i started tasting leadership and
entrepreneurship right i started tasting
this idea
of what life could look like when i was
living to my own drumbeat right and we
put on a few shows in new york city
during that time that honestly like just
were so well received from people the
the momentum of that the the feeling i
felt for of my community support it made
me just start feeling confidence and my
ability to go after my dreams right and
i think this is an important part of the
journey that we also forget is that
it's the confidence and the small stuff
that actually builds the confidence
towards the big stuff right because it's
not it wasn't okay pile just decided to
go quit her job one day and start a
company it was this series of small
steps right it was putting on a show for
150 people that went well then putting
on a show for a thousand people that
went well then saying oh wait let me
think about my life in a bigger way and
that's sort of where i was at that
moment so i wanted to explore new career
paths that i could take and that's why i
decided to go out to san francisco and
it changed my life
the point you made about
the way confidence is built i think is
so so important because i think a lot of
people think they see people like you
now sat here um after all this all
you've achieved and they think how do i
get from where i am sat on the sofa in
this job that i'm in that i hate to
being
her it seems like such a huge canyon i
have to cross that it feels like you
must be from another planet so that when
people see you at the finish line it can
sometimes be quite demotivating
but what you've just said there is in
fact there's these small it's a
staircase small one tiny step at a time
building like subjective evidence in
yourself that you you can do a little
bit more than you thought
and i'm curious as to what makes people
like you take
take that small step and it sounds like
it's you're just driven this purpose is
dragging purpose 100
if if i wasn't driven
to make an impact in the world i
wouldn't do it i mean you know you know
yes like i could go and get a good job
and do all of that and live like the
expected life and
be fine but that's not
fire right that's not me
taking my hours of 5 to 10 pm after work
and
reserving studio space and getting girls
together or you know
working till two three in the morning to
make reservations for people to get to
class like that's a very different
why right and i think that's why i go
back always to
how do you find that why like what is
that light that your life is always
about and i think you know and i feel
very blessed that i found something that
made me feel a sense of service so young
because nothing compares to it you know
no amount of money no amount of like you
know whatever press or you know any of
that is ever going to compare
to the feeling of touching somebody's
life
so many people might like again my dm's
are like how do i find my why yeah and
it feels
almost like a privilege doesn't it for
people that have
figured that out and there's people i
don't know that will be listening to
this in the morning washing the dishes
driving up and down the country in a
delivery van whatever it is thinking
i know i'm capable and deserving of more
but i just don't know what it is do you
do you believe that everybody has a
oh
a purpose beyond the nine to five
i do yeah but how do we find it yeah i
think
at the end of the day
it's it's already inside you it's
usually ourselves that are
unwilling to listen to it right
to ask yourself what did you love when
you were younger right
what when did you
light up what it who are your role
models and inspirations what's that
what's that thing you look at for a
second longer right who's that person
you want to talk to for a few minutes
more and why there is something pulling
you
there
and
you have to be willing
to go down the path of exploring it and
trying trying it right and i think
that's really the hardest thing is we
put so many blocks on ourselves right
and and i get it i mean our society
tells us this is the way to live that it
does not tell you
to live purposefully and to go and chase
your dreams i mean that's not i mean yes
we do
in the instagram world of life and
quotes i get that
but the structure of our life is not
actually built that way right and and
like you just said i mean you compared
it to
the nine to five which is about making
money right and i think actually and i
have a whole chapter where i talk about
money because
money is the most trapping thing
that's the reason people are are aren't
willing to do it
usually you know it i and i always ask
people this when they're like i don't
know if you had all the money in the
world how would you spend your day
tomorrow that's like a very good way to
start exploring what would i do without
one of the biggest constraints right
that is probably on my mind what would
truly
make you light you up right and it's not
about like buying stuff right at the end
of the day like i mean anyone who wins
the lottery like you know that they can
go buy stuff but that's not fulfillment
at the end of the day it's it's a sense
of purpose right and i think people have
to just get themselves in a place where
they're trying new things and it does
honestly feel like a privilege and
that's part of also why i started class
pass was because i wanted people to
in a way live a life that i knew i was i
was sitting there when i was in my early
20s and i would spend my you know weeks
performing for a show i'd perform on
saturday night invite people to come and
watch me dance
and i remember i felt like i had like i
said like this pep to my life and my
step and all of that
and i want everyone to have that and i
remember thinking wait a second like you
used to be an athlete like you were
training for the olympics like you were
this amazing singer and would you now
just show up and go to work all day and
don't think about finding time to even
explore these things so my contribution
to that was honestly creating class that
was like part of my very big inspiration
for it was how can i
give some of that to other people to go
and try something and potentially have
that same enlightenment in their life so
you kind of get out of your
path and your routine
and meet a teacher right that will
inspire the growth in you and that
reflection in you because most of the
times the hardest thing to do is to ask
yourself what you love in your own life
and how did you when was the moment
because i i read in i read in your book
you know there's certain pain points we
encounter where we realize okay i can
solve this problem and the sort of my
manifestation of the solution is
um this app or this website what was the
problem that you encountered and when
that made you think class pass is the
solution yeah so i was once again
training in ballet at the time i you
know i had my nine to five but every day
after work i would go and train in
ballet and i'd have my ballet clothes
with me and i'd been going to the same
teacher for about six months at the time
and i wanted to try a new class it was
just like a very
simple
thing i wanted to do i get onto you know
my computer i start browsing for this
class
two hours go by it was just this
terrible experience from a information
standpoint from you know not knowing
what class to take if it was if it's you
know close enough to me what time it
starts how do i register
and that's when i started looking at
other models that existed so there were
things you know in the us like opentable
seamless web that just made this type of
information so accessible and so easy
and convenient for a customer
that i started thinking what if i could
do this for classes and therefore get
people to get an hour out of their life
that was out of their routine to go and
do something fun and exciting so that
was really where it started
even that you kind of glossed over that
but that's pretty extraordinary because
a lot of people encounter a problem the
issue you encounter trying to book that
class and they go [ __ ] the world is not
not good enough or they think they'll
just think uh this is broken and then
they'll carry on with it oh let me
caveat that so i had come back from san
francisco 36 hours before that and when
i was in san francisco i had met a bunch
of entrepreneurs and this was my first
time ever meeting entrepreneurs right so
going back to even the whole trying new
things conversation
it was really important for me to take
that trip to sf i had been sort of stuck
in new york city i had been living this
the crazy dance life the crazy you know
nine-to-five life and i had no time for
anything else so i was not trying new
things and i needed an epiphany i needed
something to change because the two
roads i was on like they were going to
crash at some point and it wasn't going
to work
and i decided to go on this trip and
meet a bunch of entrepreneurs and i come
back thinking what if i could be an
entrepreneur let me give myself two
weeks to think of an idea that's
literally the mindset i was in
when i encountered that so 36 hours
later
i happened to be searching for this
ballet class and that's it was just like
during this perfect period in my life
and honestly like this is when i
sometimes think like does the universe
make us do these things because what are
the chances of all that happening at the
same time but it did and
i really remember in that moment
thinking i know i'm the right person to
build this because of
this background i have the communities
i've been around the experiences i have
there's probably no one else who cares
as much about dance who then also went
to mit and payne mit which is an amazing
college for those that don't know right
and it was sort of this perfect
combination of things that
made me say i got to do this and i went
for it but that is extraordinary because
a lot of people will encounter things
i'll encounter things today i might sit
on a chair and be like this chair could
be better but then i'll carry on with my
day you know what i mean and then i'll
open the fridge and go this fridge could
be yeah that's true i know that yeah
that's that feels like the pivotal
moment which a lot of people listening
to this they'll all they'll notice
things maybe they don't even notice them
because there's something in when you
start looking you know in your case
you're actually kind of looking for a
problem to solve yeah yeah
but it takes a certain character makeup
to say i
can be the one to solve this
also a little bit of delusion if you
look at the stats it's fair that's a
very good point um i was definitely
delusional at the time in thinking that
but you know what it was it was more of
i want to try
to solve this problem regardless yeah
because
it felt so tied to everything i had done
in my life i had literally fought to
dance up and ever for every year of my
life up until that point why not bring
the fight to everyone else right like
that's how i felt i was like i've
already been doing this
let's just go and you know make this
happen and and by the way like i'm also
used my you know my left brain which is
you know my analytical side to go and do
the market research and i was able to
raise money like i i definitely did this
in the practical way too and i was
making sure that it wasn't just some
crazy dream i there was there was
substance to it for sure i mean i
wouldn't have been able to raise the
capital i did i got into an incubator it
was a good idea right in the way and it
was once again it stemmed from a really
deep why in me and that was the most
important thing i think that's you know
when you know we can talk a little bit
about
the failures and the points where the
product didn't work but
i was never obsessed with getting a
product to work i was obsessed with
solving a problem from day one it's how
do i get people to class and not make it
so hard for people to get to class why
is it important for people to go to
class because then they can feel what i
have in dance in their life it was just
such a like an important
mission for me that i could just never
stop on it and every day it fueled me
because it was just so real for me to
say
i gave this to someone and even today
like you know and we've booked
like 100 million hours of workouts at
this point you know and when someone
comes to me and is and says to me like i
just went and worked out because of
class past it brings me joy because
that's an hour of their life that
was like what dances to me right that i
gave them out of their
routine or expectations or the way
society wants them to live that they did
for themselves and that is such a gift
and i think in my life i knew
fighting for that
was always a win whether it worked or
not right but what if it didn't work
if it didn't work i had a back-up plan i
mean when i say i had a back-up plan i
mean i went through my finances and my
dad and i were very clear about
how much money i had received at that
point to say i had three years to build
this i had three years before i ran out
of my own cash
and you've because you've been a saver
as it says in the business
and so that's the other thing is
you know because money can be the
biggest hurdle in going after our dreams
and if you know you're a dreamer and i
think i always knew i was a dreamer
whether i was going to spend my money to
build a company or built or put on a dan
show i knew i was always dreamer and so
i didn't care to spend money on the
smaller things in my life right like i
just didn't i didn't like i said i
didn't travel i barely went shopping and
by the way these are decisions i made
right i think it's so important i'm not
saying that because i want other people
to do the same it's it's about you
knowing and thinking about it in a very
deliberate way of how you're spending
your money
right and i was building up a savings i
didn't know what i was going to spend it
on but then when this idea came and i
got to sit down i had three years to go
after
running towards something were you
scared
um i was excited i i mean it was an
adrenaline rush you know i mean there
were times where it was terrible and
challenging and sucked and
um but i wasn't scared if i was scared i
wouldn't have done it you know i think
if my
fear trumped my
my
my confidence i wouldn't have i don't
think i would have been able to to uh
quit my job and go for it when you quit
your job and go for it at warner right
you have a meeting with the cham and the
chairman you're 28 years old
he says something interesting to you
right and i think this is this is
actually a people said people will say
to your other luck but actually it's
very much the opposite because he said
that he would invest in yeah so i mean
this goes perfectly with what we were
talking about is it's really
the reason i didn't get scared is
because more and more opportunities and
doors just kept opening for me it was
almost like the universe just started
guiding me in the most beautiful way
towards towards the mission towards the
purpose towards the answer in a way that
i felt before i was blocking it right so
the second i decided to go after
building this company one of the biggest
things i had to do was quit my job and
on the day i quit i decided to write an
email to people i had worked with my
company some executives and the vice
chairman of warner music group says hey
come to my office i'd love to hear what
you're building
go up to his office
probably the second or third time i've
ever met him in the two three years i
was there
tell him about my idea he says great i
want to invest literally writes me a
check for ten thousand dollars and gives
me an introduction into a big incubator
that was in new york city and i just
remember thinking in my head
this is this was the scariest
door i'd ever closed my life quitting my
job
but i'm literally walking out out of
here with a ten thousand dollar check
towards my next thing why did why did he
give you that check in your opinion
a few things
one
so he was a former bani so once again
reputation does follow you right like
this goes back to like everything i was
talking about in the sense of it's
always important to do good work because
if he had ever heard you know pyle is
not good i mean he knew that i was a
good worker no matter what i did even
though i didn't once again love my job i
always did good good work and i know
that i i that reputation followed me and
he knew that and we call that invisible
peel around here yeah there you go right
it's so important it shows up it shows
up yeah right exactly and i think that
was one of the big things and then i
mean two this was also like an ecosystem
where entrepreneurship was the thing but
i mean at the end of the day he believed
in me right and it was also because
you know actually this is one of my
favorite things that happened on the day
i quit is i would go and tell people
right especially people i had worked
with who were much older than me that i
was quitting my job and here i was
10 15 years younger than most of them
and i remember everyone looking at me
almost
thinking to themselves like i wish i had
the courage to do that so i think you
forget like me quitting that day was
such a sign of courage in my capability
and i didn't even realize it at the
moment but being able to make such a
bold decision at that age 28 yeah it was
a huge thing for even my vice terminacy
to say wow like
this girl is gonna go for it right and i
mean that was probably one of the first
hard decisions i had to make in my life
i had to make so many more but to
sort of have that control over your life
your thoughts your dreams
is such an important way to live and
honestly at the end of the day to be a
good leader a good ceo like you need to
be in control of your ship and in
control of your life i asked that
question about why he invested because
in my time in my company probably had
just over a thousand employees and there
was two occasions where someone said
they were quitting and they were leaving
to start a business and i went i'm gonna
invest in your business and it was
purely based on one thing which is
exactly what you've described which was
in their invisible pr they might not
even have known that i knew right but
they were great right they always did
great work that's why you have to always
do good work and yeah like i mean it's
it's such a
i and i think in this day and age people
don't feel it as much yeah even though
it might be a job you don't love we all
have to kind of in a way like you have
to earn your
or your
what does it call like earn your marks
your own strengths
earn your stripes you know and i think i
remember earning my stripes to to take
the leap for my dreams whether that was
in money or skills or and i don't regret
any of that you know and i think when
people ask me how did you do it i spent
i mean it goes back to the whole
conformity rebellious thing i was
earning my stripes so then when i felt
like i could leap i had built the
parachute in the plane you know like i i
wasn't taking a leap without anything
around me like i had built a great
structure
that was going to then let me take the
most rebellious of leaps
what that came towards the mission right
i didn't have to like rebuild all the
stuff that was about my life and like
worrying about money and this is also an
important thing is like when you are
starting a company if i'm worrying about
paying my bills right and if i'm
worrying about like do i have the skills
then i'm not worried or i'm not worrying
about the most important thing which is
can i get someone to class right like
the number one thing for me to focus on
was my business not anything that was
going on outside of that and that's why
i think it's setting ourselves up to
succeed when we are leaders when we are
entrepreneurs to be in a place where
we're not worried about the peripheral
constraints in our life we're able to
focus on the most important thing at
hand is so important for us to do it's
what's going to make us more impactful
in being able to actually solve the most
important thing i had a few words to say
about one of my sponsors on this podcast
we're now playing in a world where the
digital landscape is changing every
single day and to succeed as a small
business the most important thing you
can do is stay informed with the latest
trends and that's why i've partnered
with vodafone business they genuinely
want to help small businesses like you
navigate this fast moving space they've
developed the vhub a site containing
everything you need to get up to speed
with what's going on and you can even
ring up a vhub digital advisor for
completely free and have a one-on-one
conversation with them about your
business if you haven't checked out the
v-hub i'd highly recommend you do so as
it will help your business navigate the
changing landscape and keep you on the
front foot so go to vhub by vodafone you
can search that anywhere on google and
check it out now
we are all looking for ways to live a
little bit more sustainably and to make
more conscious choices in our day-to-day
routines so when a brand like my energy
who i've spoken about before offered to
sponsor this podcast i felt like and i
knew deep down inside that i had to help
them share their mission to create an
even greener world it feels like there's
not much more fulfilling than that and
their products provide an easy and
cost-effective way to make a sustainable
switch in your life and they've got some
existing new products coming out that i
can't wait to use myself and i'll let
you know as i use those products how i
get on so if you're a my energy customer
at the moment let me know your favorite
products down below in the comments
section and if you haven't checked them
out yet go to myenergy.com and find out
a lot more about who they are and what
they're doing if you're one of those
people that wants to make a sustainable
switch
my energy.com is the place for you
let's go to the start then of this the
class pass journey because i'm really
compelled by
you know much of the reason i started
this podcast was because
i wanted to
shine a light on the tough times in
business and i know when you're starting
a business especially a business and
tech
it can be
really really difficult because you're
sort of jockeying and pivoting to find
product market fit and to figure out
like what your customers want
how to deliver it and i read that when i
was reading about your journey when you
started um you quit your job in 2011 and
then you go through a long phase of
trying to figure out how to get people
to use this thing how to market it and
all that
nightmare talk to me about that
nightmare
so
we
went
into the market with a very clear
product idea and it was a replica of
what had worked in another industry so
opentable which allows you to book
restaurant reservations it seemed like
the right parallel to what we were doing
go on search for classes
but what i didn't realize was that there
was a very big missing part in it and i
mean i'll spare everyone like the little
details of it but everyone has to eat
everyone does not have to work out right
it was and working out usually is
something scary for people and it's more
of an aspirational thing it's not
something that you have to do every
single day so they were sort of on
different planes of people's psychology
which really became the biggest
bottleneck to what ended up happening
because we spent a year we spent
half a million dollars
building a product that didn't work and
um even though i had all this momentum
like i was saying all these beautiful
doors were opening for me and they were
and i had a lot of great you know what i
now call false signals of success like
followers press we ended up on the cover
of ink magazine without launching a
product
and all these things made me feel like i
was succeeding right because this is
what success looked like to everyone
else
and then i launched my product
and no one went to class it was like it
was and no one bought a class no one
was transacting it was crickets it was
just a really
it was this was the hardest probably a
few months of the entire trajectory
because
i i had never really faced
failure in my life i mean going back to
everything i just told you i had i'd
sort of done things well and i
tried to make sure that this would go
well right by doing everything that i
knew how how to which was let's get the
press let's build a beautiful product
let's you know get as many email
addresses as possible those are like the
obvious things that seem you know you
would do when you're building a company
but i forgot to really
ask myself if i was solving the problem
i set out to and
i
really think back to that moment and
even though it was
the hardest
that moment
is the reason
i became a real entrepreneur like i
don't think i was an entrepreneur before
that day i was
excited about solving something but the
day i failed was the day i became an
entrepreneur because that was the day i
really had to think
deeper about creating something in the
world that didn't exist
and i think it's so easy
to follow the blueprints of everyone
else and realize that entrepreneurship
is actually about having no plan and
having you know not following anyone
else's
ideas of what success is it's about
figuring out what you know what is it to
solve your mission or your you know your
business model that you're going after
and that woke me up and it was a a month
or two period where we were
trying to be comfortable like it was
this comfortable place we were in
because we had raised money we had just
come out of techstars
but
i mean it was not going well and i knew
we were going to run out of cash if like
we didn't you know figure out something
in the next few months and
um we just i remember like after a few
few weeks of it we sent this email
literally telling people to go to class
for free
thinking you know okay like this is
gonna work
we're literally paying for the classes
people have to go
and still no one went and that's when i
realized we had just gone the wrong
direction
and i needed to like circle back up i
needed to break what we had built
just think a whole new way
re-energize my team around going up
about solving this problem
in a completely new way not worrying
about what we had done
but worrying about where we're going to
go and that flipped everything and i
have been there now so many times where
i've been okay with throwing away our
past i mean people don't know this um
but class pass has changed its name
three times
it wasn't called class pass i mean even
with this time i'm talking about it was
called something else and i've thrown
away names like i've thrown away product
ideas like we've thrown we've thrown
away a lot of stuff we've changed our
pricing our plans
and it's because it's not about that
right it's about solving
the problem in the world and moving
towards that and your mission so many
entrepreneurs though and this is
probably the mistake i made when i was
18 and started my first little tech
company was um they get romantic about
that initial hypothesis being correct
exactly so it's like you've got this
square shape thing and you're just
trying to force it into this triangle
because like your ego
and there's so much relying on it and
you know the runway you know you're
running out of cash and you just maybe i
just push harder
and then all these vanity metrics can be
kind of confusing oh we've got some
false signals of success yes no one's
buying anything but we've got traffic
absolutely and as you just said like i'm
on a magazine
but then certain entrepreneurs i think
that have the humility to say in fact
it's not about being
me my hypothesis being right it's about
creating a product market fit yeah you
know and what was the moment when you
started to get closer to that product
market yeah and and to you know one of
the things i love saying about that is
to be uh mission obsessed not product
obsessed and i learned that through that
journey but um you know we started then
putting this discovery pass out there so
what we did learn is that you know we
started finally actually going and
talking to a lot of the studio owners
and talking to customers i think one of
the things that happens in tech
sometimes is you sit behind the tech
that you
you don't like go and
talk to real people right and it was
funny because i was in a tech incubator
so we showed up we were working from
like 6 a.m to 10 p.m every night but
sitting in an office we weren't actually
going to class and talking to studio
owners and all of that so once we
started flipping that we started
realizing that you know a lot of the
studio owners they were offering a free
class for people who were new they
wanted new people in the door and then
customers you know knew about all these
places but they had fears we were like
how do we break the fear and so we
started building this product our second
product which also doesn't exist anymore
it was called the passport and it was a
discovery pass where you could go and
try uh 10 different classes for 30 days
so you could go to like a spin class
monday pole dance class tuesday dance
class wednesday you can kind of you know
it was like sort of this way for people
for 50 to go and explore this is sort of
when we started realizing the whole love
of variety that people had when it came
to working out in classes which was the
magic of what we actually discovered in
our second mistake of a product is that
people loved variety they wanted to
really go and try new things it's what
motivated them they didn't want to do
the same workout every single day how
did you learn that the variety point
well people started going and like they
started loving this past right they
started loving the 30-day pass and then
they start they try to actually buy it
over and over again for the next month
and you weren't allowed to because it
was like a one-month product
and we had literally gotten these
classes for no money it was very much uh
do this for a month and then you're
gonna go find your favorite studio and
buy a pass there we thought it was
legion for the studio owners but it
ended up not being that at all people
literally were
obsessed with the variety wanted to do
it every single month and not stop and
that's when we started thinking about
what if we become a subscription we
weren't a subscription at the time it
was just this one month product and we
then started
experimenting with this idea of a class
past it wasn't even class past at the
time it was a class pass and
we launched it to about 50 customers in
june of 2013
and um they loved it the next month it
just kind of kept doubling and then it
was exponential growth and it just i
mean the sales of that took over our
other products and we just knew that the
monthly subscription was the way to go
and that that was the way that this
model was going to work and that's two
years in right three years three isn't
three years of stumbling around i mean i
went to san francisco in uh in july of
2010 and this is june of 2013. so three
years
wow one of the quotes from your book is
that um about failure being a data point
not an endpoint and i really think that
is i wish someone said that to me when i
was 18 because
um i saw failure as a testament of my
inadequacy or something as opposed to
something i should be listening to right
and that's a sort of testament to your
journey and then you know throughout
throughout that period though i think
we've
how was your as a founder something
again founders don't talk about like how
is your mental health
because i know there's sacrifice there
um let's see
a few things i would say um
i mean i sacrificed a lot especially in
those three years where we were trying
to get the product right and it wasn't
working
i mean i missed
i missed family things i missed weddings
i i was just not around right i mean i
was
literally at work all day long and if
someone on my team needed me i i gave my
150 percent to my company so
i felt fulfilled because i was doing
something i loved was i exhausted yes
was i
lonely yeah i mean i thankfully like
lived with a roommate who is one of my
like closest dearest friends till today
but
she was the only person i would see
outside of people at work you know it
was i was living in this like closed
circuit world and i don't
i don't mind that like as somebody who
has been on a mission before like has
created dan shows where they're you know
you there's this like intensity that
happens for two weeks and
you go really really intense you know
the thing that with the dan show is
though it ends at some point like you
have the show
and it's over
the thing i didn't know didn't realize
about this one is you know it's it's a
marathon not a sprint like the dance
shows can be a sprint
and that definitely got to me and i you
know one of the reasons i even developed
this entire goal setting method was
because three years in so right when i
was at this point where i realized class
was going to take off
i mean it felt like amazing right it
spent like three years i was so focused
i had literally like
probably not talked to anyone in my life
and i found myself alone for the
holidays my sister was away my parents
were in india and i was about to like
literally be by myself on christmas and
it was one of those moments for me i
always hated the holidays as an
entrepreneur because
it was the one like it was the time in
my life where i couldn't work through my
like my loneliness or through work
through any of my issues it was like the
one time where everyone
would go and do things with other people
and i would be that person who would
finally have to realize that i was on
myself right because i wasn't
cultivating relationships at that point
in my life i didn't have time to
and so it was a wake-up call and kind of
going back to you know
my mom may have been pestering me about
it for the years before
at that point in my life i just started
realizing wait a second like
i knew class was going to take off like
i just knew we i mean we only had we had
less than a thousand customers but
i had i had caught lightning in a bottle
like it was there it was so magical i
knew it was going to take over the world
like it was one of those moments as an
entrepreneur i could breathe but i
looked at everything else and i'm like
everything else is a mess my health was
a mess i could barely work out which was
crazy for me i wasn't dancing i was like
i was single i you know i had a few good
friends but i felt like i i like hadn't
been there for them and that's when i
started really doing the school setting
because i'm like i need to have
a bit more i want to make sure my
priorities are more reflective of the
human i want to be in my life
and how in like a practical sense in
terms of a time allocation sense did you
get from that place to living more in
line with those values of connection
community love and health so i you know
i'll the details of like what i did on
that session the first time i did it are
in the book but i will say this so in
the next six months uh after i started
doing that i literally met my husband a
month later really yes i decided to do a
huge dance show
at alvin ailey six months later and i
sold out a thousand uh a thousand seats
at that so i got to do a huge
performance you're gonna sell so many
books just by saying you found a husband
buy something it's really crazy but i
literally changed my
perspective around love and what i
wanted and i met my husband a month
later which was crazy and i also you
know i set goals around what i wanted to
do with class pass i set goals around my
health and how i wanted to
live and work out on a daily basis
and i did all those things and i
remember this is always my favorite
moment six months later
i was flying home on a plane
and when i first did this goal setting
method i had written it on a post-it
note because i was on a plane and i was
i was on another
plane ride because i was always
traveling and i took it out and i looked
at it and i had done everything on my
dream list
you know and sometimes just writing down
those dreams is the most important thing
but
it was just such an important moment
because i felt
more i don't i don't want to say the
word balance because that has so many
you know wrong intentions with it but i
felt that i was very clear about my
priorities and i went towards them and i
missed things too but i didn't feel
guilty about them and i just felt so
proud of myself for
saying here's what i want to do in my
life and i'm going to go and do it and
accomplishing it not just obviously
professionally but personally as well
there's like an overarching theme here
in your in your journey where the minute
you become intentional about something
yeah the door's open
it's true do you believe in that
manifestation 100
and it goes back to the you saying you
know we were talking about having a why
i think when you don't have a why you go
aimlessly and you you know i think you
start living life thinking that you want
money thinking you want to be famous
thinking you want power
and instead of thinking about like love
and passion and purpose and
whenever i have made decisions that are
about the former and not the latter i've
never been led in the right in the right
direction and you know if that's
something people can take away from this
like i think is one of it's one of the
most important points is
if you go towards purpose even if you
are rebelling right and even if you
might be pissing a few people off i
guarantee your life will be more
fulfilling
what were you like as an entrepreneur as
a leader and as a manager of people
i would say i was very much
i had a lot of positive energy i'm i'm a
small human but i
i show up with all of me um
i
am i expect a lot of people i think
because people have always expected a
lot for me so i'm sort of uh when you
start working with me
i can very quickly tell if someone's
going to like sink or swim you know
because i don't tell you a lot but i
like let you go because i think to me
that's what i've had to do is just kind
of i don't want to put a lot of boxes on
you i want you to just show me what you
can be at your highest potential and i
think like that sort of i liked giving
people that room to be free and then
allowing me to see what their capability
is versus me saying you need to be your
best in this box that i'm giving you and
i've i've found really great talent in
that way um
[Music]
i've had to learn how to like hire for
my strengths and weaknesses you know i
think um
that's probably the hardest the hardest
parts when your company grows is you do
everything in the beginning and then you
have to learn to let go and um i've
definitely learned that building a tribe
around you of great people is the only
way to succeed you struggle to delegate
right in the early days um i've gotten
better at i've got i've i've realized
that there is no other way to success
and to build big things and great things
in the world without being able to
delegate so i've become much better at
it in my life and it's the only way i i
can do what is my magical thing right
and i've i think i've put a lot of
thought into that is
what part of this company is is
something that only i know i can do
right everything else that i know
someone else can do i shouldn't be doing
is that why you delegated the role of
ceo yes absolutely at some point a ceo
title becomes a lot of you know managing
investors managing team
doing press and i was like this is not
what i want to be doing with my time i
want to be solving the problem i want to
be in with my customers working on like
interesting concepts not spending my day
in a bunch of meetings that you know
didn't feel inspiring so i think like
you know and everyone's set up
differently you have to know how you
work that's another big thing is is
learning the insights of what motivates
you like it's it's the work you do and
why you do it that ends up really
mattering right in any job you're in and
i remember there was a point where i
remember being
so
just disheartened and not wanting to
show up to build my own company and i'm
like what is going on it was because i
hated the work i was doing and i loved
obviously my company but i hated the
actual work that i had to do and so i
had to figure out a way to get past that
it was like 20 like 16 17. i mean we
were launching like around the world it
was so intense it was you know i mean it
was magical like i said it was
incredible to build that but i remember
like i said i was showing up every day
dealing with like hr issues legal issues
like needing to talk to my investors i
wasn't like around my customers and i
wasn't going to class and around my
product you know and that's what really
fuels me as an entrepreneur and a
founder did you have email dread like i
used to at one point i remember when my
company was getting big because there
was lots of chaos in my company there's
all kinds of cash flow issues i used to
like dread opening my emails i was like
it's going to be some other [ __ ]
from like
an investor or something yeah i mean i
definitely i wanted to make sure that
i had more to look forward to and i
think there came a point where i was
looking forward to less and less right
and i think it goes back to what i was
saying about
i didn't want my whole day to be like
ugh okay there's like another competitor
okay we need to worry about this now i
didn't want my days to be about worrying
i wanted my days to be about dreaming
right and by the way you have to
obviously as a leader of any of this it
comes with a responsibility right so
it's not that
it's not that i didn't have to worry
about those things there were certain
parts of it that i knew i had to worry
about i needed to be on my radar but i
knew there were certain things where i'm
like i could hire someone to really work
on this and fix this it doesn't need to
take up my time and energy and that's
really where where the combination is or
where that decision lies
so all of that passion all of that love
driven by this really deep intrinsic why
why did you step away from class pass
you know i think at some point
and this happens i think for so many
founders i mean it had been a decade of
my life solving this problem which of
course i'm so
deeply passionate about and you know i
think the earliest days were when we did
the most leg work and actually like
figuring out the product you know
the product nuances that were going to
actually like unleash the behavior i
think it just got bigger you know for me
i think there are other things i want to
do in the world and there's probably
other problems in the world i still need
to go and solve and it's on me to
unleash myself to be able to face them
so i can move forward towards them and
have them even come into my periphery i
think if you're kind of stuck in the
past you don't even welcome the doors
right that are that you need to go
through to reach your future and
i know for me my
my future
is waiting for me you know and it's on
me to sit there and walk through the
door and go towards it and was there was
there a feeling of like a loss of
love
yeah i mean it's a bittersweet moment
you know it was um
it's super bittersweet right
i always say this like the the hardest
day was when
i stopped getting my my class pass email
i mean like it was insane i've had this
email for for years it was like my main
inbox and um
[Music]
you know it was it was definitely a
sense of loss i mean i think it's you
know
for it's like having a child and
watching your child get married right
but it's also being able to say like
they're okay i i did all i could
to get them to this point and being
proud of that and that's really where
i'm at i remember the
when i resigned from my company went
public and i said to the company i said
i'm going to resign but i have one
caveat they're like what is it i was
like i want to keep my email
oh you didn't use that
my email
i still have my you know it's funny that
you say that i think i did it going back
to the whole
uh it was just been more noise right for
me
i just think it was it was a nice break
for me i actually remember creating a
new email address and it was like no
mail
what you know and it was it was
interesting because it started making me
realize like what do i want to fill that
part of my life up with what's the
answer what's the answer to that i'm
sort of in the middle of it still but
you know obviously
lots of dance you know i think i
probably have a few more big problems in
the world to solve you know i'm i'm only
39 you know it's interesting because
i'm young you know my mom and i always
talk about this too and she's like it's
interesting because
yeah like i could retire them no there's
no part of me that would ever think
about that you know but
it's an interesting it's a great place
to be the valuation of class pass at
sale is probably confidential as it
tends to be but um i know that in 2020
in the series he rounded was valued at
over a billion
it's a lot of money
how does that change things for you
um
well you know we haven't exited so like
the company hasn't been been sold yet so
it's still private but um is your stake
acquired or your stake is still in the
company my stake is still in the company
yeah so it's not fully you know fully
there but you know i think these and
here's the thing the reason why that was
such an important moment was because of
what it really the message it sent for
women especially and me being you know
an indian woman like that was actually
the most important part of it i don't
think as an entrepreneur you should run
towards numbers like that because what
you should run towards is making an
impact right the 100 million hours of
people's lives is actually much more
impactful to
my business and society than hitting
that billion dollar evaluation but in my
case i think it's different because i
know what that represents
to so many other
girls out there who can look at
something and say wow if she can do it
maybe i can too
and that to me is a really important
part of it and that wave of press
whenever whenever someone becomes a
unicorn is tremendous right and that
will reach so so many young women all
over the world and entrepreneurs
your partner
your son completely other part of your
life nick zane yep nick and zayn how's
that been you know
you talk about the obsession you've had
building class pass
um entrepreneurs always struggle and
tend to struggle in managing their
romantic relationships in the other part
of their life what advice have you got
for me on maintaining a good romantic
relationship and family whilst also
striving to build big dreams yeah and i
i'll be honest i think we're always
still learning in the process of it but
i think one of the biggest things i
learned is and this goes along with a
lot of the advice i have with my parents
is bringing them along the journey
nick was
with me through so much of it i mean
when we went to go launch london
um i always actually love this story is
me one of uh my co-founder and
one of my uh sales sales girls cam came
with me and so did nick and we had to go
try out about 30 studios in in london in
about five days and nick just went and
did some of them too like it was amazing
we all just went and worked out and he
was sort of like checking out studios
because we before we put anything on the
platform we wanted to make sure they
were vetted studios and this was like i
said it was like six seven years ago so
it wasn't that much that many reviews on
studios
and um yeah like i mean he would come to
australia with me come to london with me
and he was just a big part of the
process you know and i think that's so
awesome that we got to live like he got
to live the dream with me
and i think that was a really nice part
of it i think as we've had a kid we've
just had to become very clear on
priorities right and he is and he's a
partner at a law firm he's you know one
of the youngest partners at his law firm
it's insane
what he's been able to accomplish in his
career so we have to just always be very
very communicative on what we both want
right in setting goals and hey like what
do we want to accomplish this year in
terms of our lives right the same way i
think about it personally we have to
think about it in terms of what our
family wants to do whether it's like
school whether it's traveling right what
do we want to make sure we both do
as a family unit combined with you know
our jobs and our ambition you know and i
think it's so important especially for
women
to surround themselves with partners and
people who will constantly help them
stay ambitious in their life because
it's one of the hardest things what if
there's conflict between when you think
about what the family wants to do and
what pile wants to do
as in terms of your ambitions and then
his ambitions with his career do you
have to talk it out and come up with a
plan you know i to me a plan
is the most important thing and
sometimes there is conflict but you have
to try new things similar to pivoting
right and iterating like on a company
you sometimes both people have to be
flexible to be like okay well like if
this current situation isn't working
we're gonna try something new right okay
like you want this i want this what if
we try a combination of this for six
months what if we you just have to be
flexible and adaptable i think the
biggest mistake
is not doing anything
and staying sort of stagnant in a place
where someone's uncomfortable or
someone's not happy
and
not helping the other person right at
the end of the day
nick being happy in his life is going to
make him the best husband to me and the
best dad and me being happy in my life
is going to make me the best mom and
best wife to him right and we both know
that so it's about saying what does
happiness look like
to both to us individually but then us
together as a family your journey has
weaved and up down left right all of it
it's been a tremendous roller coaster
with so many highs and lows and
everything in between you spoke earlier
about the importance mentorship has
played in your life have you ever been
to therapy
have i ever been to therapy um i did a
little bit of therapy actually at the
beginning of last year um
you know it was i had a baby by the way
six weeks before the pandemic
and then like my company came to a hall
it was just a really crazy time so i had
just
gone to therapy to just start talking to
somebody because i didn't even know how
to make sense of so much of where my
mental state was at that point i hadn't
seen people i'd literally been a mom for
a year living at home right it was just
my life was so different than what it
looked like pre-pandemic at that point
and so i yeah i have and i i mean i
recommend it to anyone it's it's sort of
like a fitness instructor who works on
your body you need to work on your mind
sometimes and see you know what your
roadblocks are right we know them like
oh my god i feel i don't feel strong
with my left arm like how do you get
that stronger we sometimes have blocks
like that too
and it's sometimes
for me it's been like sometimes there'll
be a feeling which i can't but you just
know you're out of orientation or
something's not right i think the
pandemic did that to a lot of us which
was yeah destabilized our us in many
many ways um your journey is phenomenal
it's really really phenomenal and you're
a really phenomenal person for so many
reasons one of the reasons why is just
you're just this from like the minute
you walked into this room you're just
this like ray of sunshine oh thank you
and that's why i think i asked the
question about like therapy and your
hard moments in particular because
you have you have just an unbelievable
smile and you have such an it you i'm
like is this person always this this
this
you know but it goes down to i always
believe there's the light right like i
think
it's the question you we started with it
was
i just
believe there's like goodness to give
and service and and purpose and
when i'm
not aligned with my purpose i do feel
sad right those are my like hardest
moments where
you know if i didn't care about sharing
you know my insights and stuff like i
could be you know somebody who wasn't
happy but i i do things intentionally
and therefore how can you not be happy
doing the things that you love in your
life
so beautiful we have a closing tradition
okay
the previous guest writes a question for
the next guest oh okay and they don't
know who they're writing it for
what is one thing
you would do
if you weren't
afraid
at all
you know it's interesting i'm i like
mentally
i
don't have many things that
i don't feel like i could solve so it's
like not mental i i probably have more
physical things because i'm such a small
per like i'm 411 right it's like it's an
interesting thing because
i feel more physically fearful of things
than i do actually you know what i would
do i would do
i would run a marathon
interesting
i love running i just have never run
that you're afraid
i'm not probably not afraid but
potentially i'd have to work through
what's holding me back from it but maybe
there is some fear
i'm gonna pay attention see if you end
up running a marathon thank you so much
for your time and your wisdom it's so
you're such a breath of fresh air for so
many reasons but you're a real source of
inspiration and what you've um what
you've accomplished with with class past
is just astounding it really is
astounding and yours like humility and
openness to share the truth about that
not just in the book but but here today
is i'm going to be liberating for a lot
of people and that the whole you know
one of the key lessons i come away with
even though i feel like i
i might have said this if you'd asked me
it's just the unbelievable importance of
having and following that voice inside
of us which is there and all the reasons
we suppress it because of external
whatever whatever but you know um
as as you i was sitting there as you're
talking i was thinking you know what as
well the other thing is like even if you
you try and do something else whether
it's
management consulting whatever you're
never actually going to master it yeah
because it's always going to be a
tedious job when you ended up mastering
the thing that was in line with your
passion and i think that's a really
important lesson to everybody who feels
like they're in a situation now that
might not be in line with that voice
inside right
thank you be the master of you a man
yeah you're brilliant thank you so much
for your thank you thanks for having me
stephen i had a few words to say about
one of my sponsors on this podcast as
the seasons have begun to change so
how's my diet and um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent um so 81 of the days i've
done a workout in the last 150 days
right so i'm going to the gym about six
times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivative live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]